this video is sponsored by
curiositystream and by my nebula
original more on that later
also the shot's going to look a little
weird a little wide because it is the
start of september 2020 as we record
this
and we're following all the uk industry
regulations for filming covert safe
all right enjoy the show in 1927 helen
adelaide shelby of oakland california
applied for a patent
an apparatus for obtaining criminal
confessions and photographically
recording them
it was basically a lie detector if you
knew the suspect was guilty but you
couldn't prove it
you would use a device like this which
as far as i know was never built and
never used
until now i have commissioned my friend
charles to make one
we've updated some of the technology
we're using a modern camera instead of
bulky reel-to-reel film but
this is as true to the patent as we
could make it and we're going to test
out
the shelby's lie detector for the very
first
time daniel tom chloe thank you very
much for coming along we're going to
test a 1927 lie detector
today sure why not i haven't
told you all anything else
there's a lot of trust in this room
isn't it i'm not feeling it
i hope it's not based on heart rate
because i am anxious now
[Laughter]
here's the plan there is a cookie on the
table
just here i'm gonna leave the room one
of you steal the cookie
i miss him already there was never any
doubt in my mind that it has to be you
oh no no i don't know you are the best
liar out of us
right so the cookie is gone you all have
water bottles now
which i feel like one of you went to get
some water after eating a cookie and
then the other two were like we should
all have water now
it's an interesting theory watson not
homes here
the sidekick who doesn't know anything
thank you right i'm going to start over
here
chloe did you take the cookie
tom did you take the cookie no
i don't know why for some reason i
didn't believe that but okay
daniel did you take the cookie no
okay so chloe i believe immediately i
know everything i'll say
i'm not gonna even try and do an
official guess here my gut reaction is
that it's one of you two
possibly both of you two maybe you split
it to try and trip me up i i don't know
so chloe would you please come join me
at the 1927 lie detector
i'd love to we put daniel and tom in a
separate room so they couldn't hear
chloe's reaction to
whatever was inside the box oh there's
two cartons okay
with both those curtains closed it was
pitch black inside
well very dark there was an infrared
camera in there but chloe genuinely
could not see anything
so it's probably a good time for earlier
me to tell you what she's about to face
although if you've seen the title of the
video you've probably worked it out
the problem is that this lie detector is
ridiculous the patient uses very long
and flowery language but in short
there is a skeleton hidden at the end of
the box a curtain rises to reveal it and
the suspect will be startled convinced
by this genuine supernatural apparition
from the beyond which for some reason
will
make them confess the truth as their
interrogator asks questions from behind
the box in a spooky voice
i'm not kidding that's the patent the
shelby whoever she was never lived to
see her invention made real and
perhaps that's for the best because
patents don't have to be
good they just have to be new but with
that in mind
let's try it anyway chloe's first
reaction was probably not what the box's
inventor would hope for
oh oh no oh god i can read into my soul
did you taste the cookie
no i'm sorry was i meant to
i are you are you sure yes
unfortunately yeah thank you
you may leave the box oh okay
yes sir thank you sir
no confession so far so how about tom
cool tom later told me that he has a
phobia of theme park characters and
things like this
oh god oh geez and as he entered the box
he realized that he'd read about the
crime skeleton somewhere
i know what this is i am so upset
so first of all brave no
[Music]
oh there you are i knew it did you
take the cookie i did not
miss the spooky scary skeleton i
didn't i promise are you sure
i sure am cause that's what chloe said
as well
is this one of those like if if i'm i
absolve myself she goes to jail because
yes she did it she totally did it
thank you for your time
you may leave the box thank you
actually quite nice i was quite worried
when we met but you're
surprisingly hospitable
okay i'm trying
that was horrible two down one to go
oh god dan was worried
oh my god i hate every second of this
uh oh my god although i didn't expect
the full-on yell of terror
oh my god hi
did you take the cookie
no are you sure i
am certain that i didn't take the cookie
because that's what everyone else said
hmm you you definitely didn't take the
cookie
was it your cookie because you are
looking a little bit like you could do
with a good dinner
please leave the box okay
how do i get out of the box if there's
curtains you can open
then i talked so uh that didn't work
that wasn't much at all it could have
there was a moment in there where i
never admitted to anything was it the
moment
before you saw the skeleton yeah the
second the second skill didn't happen i
was like oh it's fine
yeah it was a lot scarier before the
skull showed up
no it didn't work no i have no idea so
based
purely on like initial reactions i don't
think it was you
if you two didn't split it then i think
it's damn
whoever stole the cookie stone yes
i i was right about one thing two of
them had split the cookie
but it was dan and chloe this invention
does not work just like every other
my detector i've got a nebula original
with five creators that you might
recognize competing for real
money but it's not just me you know real
engineering nebula original
alex from technicality who had a guest
video on my channel years ago
nebula original window of productions
two nebula originals minute physics well
minute body is their nebula original
plus loads of other single
and collaborative series and ad-free
podcasts and you can get it for free
when you join curiosity stream a
subscription streaming service with
thousands of big-budget professional
documentaries and non-fiction titles
curiosity stream is just 2.99 a month
including access to nebula and
all those series and right now you can
get 26
of an annual plan by going to
curiositystream.com
tom scott if you have three dollars
going spare go check it out
thank you so much to daniel j legend to
thomas tomska ritual to chloe scarf
demon dungate
all their channels are linked around
here somewhere and thank you in
particular to
charles arnold who built the amazing
crime detecting skeleton
that's it happy october everyone